I'm the case of the Brazilian cartoonist tuf
The account of a cartoon I made
showing a prime minister netanyahu
from israel
twisting a child's corpse
where the vote came from in an
I was rated the third highest index
the most representative key
of the Arab Spring in the Egypt Area was
that of a young man who had been
who was tortured and killed by the
Egyptian policeman holding with his a
a bar here I usually say that
mike brown was killed twice
he died by the bullet of the policeman and
died by the decision of the jury court
in Ferguson that cleared the policeman who
killed him
so you have a black mother hugged
with the son also in school uniform
shot
in the background a favela and the police
smiling
this demonstrates well through the image
this situation of extermination of
black and poor population that people
verified in the works in Brazil is the state
it's a state policy
So when you have a police officer that
has as a preferred target the black and
poor
he is actually instituting a
official racism an institutional racism